OF PILOT BEFORE
VIRGINIA.
NEW FO> WE BEGINH EXCLUSIVE NEW
EPISODOFAGO DOCUMENTS CASE.RM TA
SIGNS DID BE IN
E L STAGES.
WALKH THIS
>> OKAY.
RR WITH IT WAS IST OCTOBER, WE
WERE T THIMATEE
WORKER AT A-IN
PO. THEY DRAINED THE ,  C FLOOD
THIS ROOM THATARE
STORE THE SURVEILLANCE FOOTA
THAT'S IMPORTANTECKN
PROSECUTS HA BN LOOKING AT
THE SURVEILLANCE FMAR-A-LAGO.
THEY'VE SUBPOENAED ISEL
TIMES.E REQUESTED THAT
NON INTENTNAL OONG IT WAS GE
MI
E MAE WORKER, WHO
S E ONE WHO DRTHCTER T BUSY
SEASON AT MAR-A-LAGO, I SHOULD
HE
THEY'VE SEIZED HIS PHONE.
LKED THIM.
HE'S SOMEONE WHO I ORVEILL F T
HAOVG BOXES AT
WE DON'T KNOIC
BOXES, BUT HE S  BOXES
WITH ANOTHER TRUMP AIDE.
WHEN ICOS TOERROLE THAT HE PLAY
ABOUSEE AT SOMEONE HAS TESTIO
THESRVORED THAGED WH THIS FLOODR
KEPT T
SUSPICIOUS,
ASKIN
WITNESSES ABOUIT AND RAISING
QUESTIONS ABOUT IT.
THERWAY OBSTRUCTION IN TG
THEIR VE'S JUSAN ODD  THA AOT O.
>>EAH.
CERTAINLY.
DO WE KNOW?>> WE KNOW A LOT OF
GIVEN ER
BUT  H RAISING
HAT WEWE LEARNED SO MUCH OF WHS
I'M TOLD.E ASKED ABOUT GAPS IN
SURVAN.
FOR THE SECUWERE
RG THE
SECURITY FOOTAGEN TI
OFT EXACTLY WARNED OVER.
TRUMATTORNEYS HAVE SAID THATEVE
TRUMP ORGANIZAE SUBPOENAS.
T OF
QUESTIONN ATN
UT.
>> WHAT WE KNOW ABO TWEES LAWYT
HADAY.I'M TOLD JACK SMITH, THE L
COUNSEL, WHO IS INVESTIGATING
TH DOCUMENTS AND
WAS IN THAT
G.
THEY REQUESTED AM TTORNEY GENER
MERRICK GARLAND.
THEY WROTE H A LETTER.
EGE THERE WAS SOME
THEY DIDN'T REALLY SAY WHAT.
IT WASTTY BROAD STROKES.
WEW OBVIOUSLY THOUGH,
INDICTED, THEIR TOS WOULD KE TO.
THAT'S NOTE TOLDS
THCONTENT OF THI
I NG QUESTIONS
ABOUT E
THEY HRONT
THIS HAS BEED.THEY W JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT FOR ABOUT 90 MINUTE
N CHARGED. WAS SAYING OSEN
WE KNOW THAT THEY TOLD TO BE CH
ANYTHIBU
REFERENCING.
>> I KNOW RE
ANCHORING AT 9:00. WORKED ON TH.
>>> TO GET A BETTER SENSE OF
WHAT GON IE MEETINGS
AND WHAT GOEINNSNTS, W JD BY
ANDREW McCABE.
S IN A MEETING
LIKE THIS S AND DOJ >> SURE.
DELSO T AVOIDING GETTING YOUR
CLIENT DEFENSE
ATTORNEYIRST AND BIGGEST GOLAST
CALLY G ALONG ESLINES.E ATTORNEO
DOJ WH. OA ILY LIKE YOU WOULD SN
COME IN,NDSAY  NE LAST D ET ER
KNOW, THEY'LL MAKE AN ARGUMENT
FORWAR HAVE OFNCE.L USUAD BENF
ERTOO SO.
CAARHING SD ONTHER SIDE
ALL THE TIME THEY'VE REQUESTED.
AND AT END OF THE
CWE'LL VE A CAL
ANYTHING T YOU.
'S AONG-SHOT STREGY.IT WIF
A DEFENSE ATTORNEY
BULY NOT
E  WHEN
CLAI PROSECUTORIMISCONCTOT E SME
ME
THIS MAY JUST BEAST DITCH
EFFORT TO DO CAN.
>>
I THINK IT'S HIGHLY UNLIKELY
THAT THEY HAVE SIGNIFICANT
EVIDENCE O, SIMPLY EMENTS OTH
INVESTIGATHAVE BEEN
FEROCIOUSLN
THE TWO
,
INRV OVEIGSTIGATION.
HAD, OF COURSE,RC
JUSTICE WENT B OF D D E WHEN
S AGAINST THE TRUMP
THEY'VE GONE IN AN
EFRTPIERCE TRNEY/CLIENT PRIVIL .
THERE'S BEENOTF JUDICIAL TION.
F THERE WAS ACTUAL
BUT MY SUSCI HERE,
THE ONLY WAY TO GET NEY
GENERAL TO REALL
REMOVE OR STOP SPECIAL CEL
HA O
UNTHL T' THEAN TURN OFF, AN
RNN F,
SPECIAL COUNSEL EFFORT, IS IF
SPECIAL COUNSEL
ENGAGED IN MISCONDUCT.
IRE HIM, AVE TOTHAT TO
THAT IG  LITERALLY SWINGINNCES.
>> BASED ON YOUR EXPERNCYOU BELN
I DOLD COMRYKLY.TORNEYS TRYING
JU GRANDT BEFORE
CASE.
SO, I THINK WE C ST
HAENME NOW, AN
RTEXT W
WEEKS.
WE'VE ALSO SEEN ALL THR
WITNESSES THAT WE'RE AWARE
THE A GRAND .AVE ALRDY
WELRNDERSTAND THERE'S A
VIE TO
RK, JUST WHEN THE
THINGS THEY'VE BEE
REPORTED, THEY LIKELUCH
MO.
I THBLINTS
NAES ON THE
>> WHAT DO Y THINK
S REPORT
A-OOD RAIS
SUSPICIONS AMONGSE THAT'S A REA
ONE.
ITER AN
SUSPICIOTHKNOWCH HAS OE OTHER.I
WE KNOW THAT FROE
WARRANT APPLICAT, EY
EVERY POSSIBLE ACT AS
POSSIBLE -U OWAS A PBLN.HIS CASE
TEAM IS ACLY CLAIMINATPRODUCE T
REQUESTED UNDE
BECAUSE  DTHEY'RE ACTUALLY USINI
LIKEMEANPOINT? SO, OBSTRUCTIYO
OBCTION, YOU HAVLE
TO PROVE THEY INTENDED T
IDDING OROOM WITH CO MORE EVIDE
INNTOP OR OBSTRUCT TIN THIS CASA
CH
>> RIG. H, NV YE YOUE
R
E DOCSRE
AVAILABLE TO B